you know this better than anyone the the
presidential races more so than Senate
races even more so than house races more
so than Governor's races like you have
to go out and actually show that you can
appeal to people right because these
early states are not California they're
not Texas they're not Ohio right they're
they're not states where you can just
run a bunch of TV ads and introduce
yourself to people you have to like go
and meet people you can run for Senate
in some ways easier in terms of like
lacking a winning personality than you
can run for president the presidential
race like it or not is very personality
driven
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast one of my former colleagues from
CNN you may know him from his show the
point he has a book coming out in April
Power Players about sports and the
presidency he's now on sub stack my
friend Chris saliza welcome Chris
hello sir thanks for having me it's
great to see you I'm trying to remember
the last times we hung out in person I
do vividly remember a basketball game in
New Hampshire I think that was the time
yes and I think it was officially a draw
though I think you might have gotten the
better of me is that what what happened
no no you're you're amending history you
beat me oh wow that's kind I I think if
if I did beat you I think you were
taking it easy on the presidential
candidate so thank you
I never take it easy I only have one
speed well then I feel all the better
about it then so uh you're one of the
most plugged in political reporters uh
in in the country uh you and I hung out
in the early States I know right now New
Hampshire is having a bit of a meltdown
because uh the the Democrats might have
deposed them I made a couple of big
predictions we're going to open up with
2024 which is what most people think
about unfortunately when they think
about politics
that is true that is true you're right
yes so I made a couple of predictions
um to open up the year in 2023.
um so number one I said that Joe Biden
runs for reelection uh and uh that if he
well first let's start there uh are you
hearing anything different
um
months ago I think it was more of an
open question like there were definitely
people you could find who knew Biden who
said you know he hasn't made his mind up
uh sort of depends how these next few
months go depends how like every how he
how he feels how Jill his wife feels
um it seems to me that doubt has
disappeared uh in those six months I
think whether it's getting done the
things he got done whether it's the
prospect of trump again you know
obviously Trump is the only announced
candidate for president at the moment uh
and I would say the front runner for the
Republican nomination uh I don't know
what it is I would say barring some sort
of Health crisis right like he goes and
has a physical before he announces and
they find something God forbid I can't
imagine him not running uh at this point
though you know he'll be
82 when he isn't if if and when he is
curated for another term in 86 by the
time he finishes that term so
obviously those would break all records
for the oldest person ever to to be in
office and I do think this age will be
an issue uh in the campaign how big of
one I mean Trump is not uh the youngest
you know Trump is
76 77 uh so
how big an issue it is that Trump is the
nominee you know it's hard to make an
argument about generational change when
you're you know two years younger than
the president but uh I do think Biden
runs I do think that one is right again
I think we always have to caveat it with
you know until he says I'm running for
president we don't know but I everything
points in that direction yeah one thing
that points in that direction is that no
one else is running
exactly at least there's like a a void
shall we say not no one else I mean I I
can think of at least one person I think
is going to throw their hand in the ring
on the Democratic side but that person's
not part of the democratic establishment
when I was in South Carolina last week
uh I asked and they said that no one in
uh the Democratic circles has been
organization building or reaching out or
testing the waters and I think no one
will for fear that you get Crossways
with the current president United States
and that hurts you down the line if if
Biden had internally to sort of the the
establishment of the democratic party
said I'm undecided or I'm leaning
against it I think you would see some
people making trips to Iowa making trips
to New Hampshire making trips to South
Carolina
uh they would cover it and say wow I'm
just you know visiting the state it's
always been important to me right but
like there's a reason that they go to
those three states and not the other 47
States
um you haven't seen that again which I
think is even more evidence to your
point that they've been told internally
he's very likely to do this again and so
it's not in their political best
interests to get on his bad side by like
going to do an event in South Carolina
while he's still ostensibly making up
his mind by the way the people in South
Carolina I spoke to were hoping that he
doesn't run because they want a
competitive race because that that would
mean a ton of attention and resources uh
to them and then if Joe does run it's uh
essentially uh James Clyburn coronation
uh repeat I think that the little dirty
little secret of every early voting
state is they want
they want as much money time and
attention to be spent in that state as
possible I mean that's now I do think
um you know on the Republican side Nikki
Haley is going to run former South
Carolina governor uh so you know and
obviously Trump's in the race and I
think the Santos will be in the race so
so I think you're going to have a
competitive at least a quasi-competitive
race on one side but I think it's
unlikely uh barring a big surprise from
Biden I think it's very unlikely you see
a terribly competitive race in any of
these early States like you said there
will definitely be a candidate or two
who run sort of for their own either
their own interests or to to
um push try to push an issue into the
into the Limelight but those people
don't have any reasonable expectation of
winning right they're they're it's not
it's not as though it's it's a campaign
that's based on this is going to end in
Victory it's a campaign based on I want
to get this issue for it or I want to do
something with my profile those kind of
candidates May well run but I don't see
any serious challenge to Biden emerging
in South Carolina or anywhere else well
when you talk about the the the
seriousness of the challenge I mean a
lot of it I said this on
CNN a couple months ago I don't think
the DNC is going to play fair like I
think the dnc's interest in having their
sitting President Joe Biden who will be
81 when this is going on uh standing
there debating multiple times multiple
candidates they're going to totally
short-circuit that process if let's say
they set a debate threshold of hey you
need to be pulling at 15 percent and
then had a couple upstarts pulling at 15
I think they would just raise it to 25
percent
and like make it into as much of a
non-uh race as possible
they're just to make it a non-race for
two reasons one because they don't want
to spend any money that they don't have
to spend they don't want Biden to spend
any money that they don't have that he
that he doesn't have to spend not on the
general election but two you mentioned
the debate thing and I think it's worth
revisiting you know Joe Biden whether
you think he's been a good president or
a bad president is not a terribly good
candidate for president you know he lost
twice uh 88 in 2008 he won a race that
was you know I I think I'm trying not to
exaggerate recency bias here but but one
of the weirdest races that we've ever
[Laughter]
no it was a
you know
it was going against Biden until South
Carolina that he won South Carolina and
then the race effectively sort of ended
because of covert I mean there was no
you know after that one super Tuesday
that Biden did pretty well but Bernie
Sanders was still a relevant serious
candidate and had it not been for
coveted would have continued to run you
know the race kind of ended that early
in early March 2020 and so it's not even
as little Biden I mean look you could
always argue Hillary versus Barack Obama
look it went all the way to the end they
went all the way to June 6th of of that
year
um running against one another so you
know Obama won that race uh you know for
Biden I don't know how well he wears as
a candidate uh I think he's not a great
debater
um I I don't think any of those things
would preclude him from being in the
nominee again with the names that I hear
mentioned as possible candidates even if
they did get on a debate stage with Joe
Biden I still think Joe Biden would wind
up winning I don't know if he would be
as convincing on a debate stage as some
people would like him to be which is why
it's in the sort of establishment
Democrats interest to keep this race
as non-competitive as possible when you
talk about names of folks who might run
on the Democratic side I've heard Marian
Williamson I've heard Nina Turner have
you heard any different no Marianne
Williamson is the one sort of you know
who who we know has done this in the
past
um you know she had moments during the
last race uh I think people were
interested in her as kind of an oddity
more than as someone who was a serious
candidate ah I could see her running I
could see me in a Turner running sort of
as a lefty alternative to Biden again
those are people I think who would get
single digits given given the way
everything is currently structured now
with the DNC with the rules
um and bylaws committee with everything
being set up with South Carolina
apparently going first obviously would
be Joe Biden's strongest State among the
early States it's the only one he won
among the early States
um everything seems to me to be pointing
to a
relatively easy victory for him I do not
think this is Carter Kennedy in 1980 you
know I I don't see a
Senator or a sitting member of the
cabinet or anything like that running I
I just again I think those people who
it's like you said those people who run
will do so for they have their own
reasons they have their own agendas that
they're trying to put forward but I
don't think winning is at the top of
those agendas because I think it's just
very unlikely it's very hard to beat
incumbent president anyway even if you
are say Ted Kennedy as we saw in 1980 uh
so I think that it's
it's very unlikely anyone other than
Biden winds up as a nominee even if we
get a random member of Congress who runs
you know which I think again it's
unlikely but are you hearing that are
you hearing that no I am not uh but but
I could see if you're a lefty you know
kind of liberal member of Congress and
you want to sort of raise your profile I
could see it but like the likes of
Alexandria ocasio-cortez or someone like
that she's just not there's no reason
for her to run she already has a
national platform I think it's unlikely
she would beat Joe Biden in a in a
Democratic primary just because all the
advantages that we just talked about you
know so anyone who I think could win
wouldn't run and look at this and say
look a worst case scenario for them
politically speaking Joe Biden it wins
and his president until 2028 and then
it's open and many of these people are
young and can wait
foreign
I've always been a mattress guy it's one
reason I'm so thrilled that this podcast
is sponsored by Helix sleep Helix sleep
is the future of mattresses you take the
Helix sleep quiz at their website and
get your perfect mattress fit in under
two minutes it takes a little longer for
them to get that to your door but when
they send it to your door you get a
hundred night free trial I know it's
crazy that's over three months and then
over a 10-year warranty to try out your
new Helix mattress it's become the go-to
mattress for my kids in the house and
they have a few mattresses to choose
from but they just always seem to find
this one you don't need to take my kids
word for it it's also the number one
mattress pick by wired GQ imagine that
job just trying out mattresses for
magazines but it's number one and it's
number one for a reason Helix is
offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com yang
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now
[Music]
first let me say I'm I'm friends with
Marianne Williamson and I'd like you to
admire her great deal I think she's uh
much more serious thoughtful figure uh
than most uh gave her credit for and
I've written it as much
um and she endorsed me and uh or uh we
campaigned together in various ways
um and I spent a lot of time with her
like I'm a big fan of hers what you said
about Joe being a like a bad campaigner
or like maybe a not great candidate
um so I had a ringside seat to that
obviously and one of the things I say to
folks is that uh the more people saw of
Joe the less well he did I mean that's
like just a it's a tough observation but
uh the the folks in Iowa and New
Hampshire I spoke before or after Joe
Biden a dozen times and he's he you know
at the time he was uh you know if he's
80 now I guess he'd be like you know he
was 77 at the time or something along
those lines 76. uh and he he wasn't that
compelling uh an in-person presence or
speaker over the 2020 campaign again
like I I don't think the DNC wants
anything to do with him having to
campaign in these states
um or have debates with uh with these
figures and and so I I think you wind up
with something along the lines of what
you're describing
um though I do think if you had a very
credible alternative to Joe of any
ideological bent I I think that they
would actually get some real oxygen in
part because the folks in the early
States uh one to your to what we said
before it's like they just kind of want
some action they want some energy like
then it's like uh you know it's a dud
for them
um but the other thing is that there
there's a significant
proportion of
Democrats who the polling shows are like
really uncomfortable with
um inaugurating an 82 year old president
and and that first that percentage is a
bit higher among Independents and
whatnot I I will say too that like I
share that discomfort just in the sense
that you know Common Sense like if you
had a really really stressful job
um would you bring in the you know the
the uh octogenarian uh and if you do
that then are you in essence voting for
his running mate
um who I expect to be Kamala Harris uh
because I don't see any way he can make
that change
yes a couple things one Kamala Harris
will be the Vice Presidential nominee
he's not going to I think one of my
favorite slash most ridiculous
storylines and it happens every four
years from the incumbent president is
the he or she is going to trade out
what's a he I guess because we've never
had a female president he is going to
trade out uh the the nominee for vice
president that that this is the time
that it's going to happen and every four
years there are stories about it it's
going to be they're gonna move into a
more popular they're they're not getting
along and every four years it winds up
they nominate I mean yes uh vice
presidential nominees were swapped out
in the 19th century in the 20th and 21st
century it just doesn't happen and so I
think there will come a time because
there always comes a time every four
years where there will be a story or
stories written about like tensions are
high between Biden and Kamala Harris and
it will will they will they potentially
she's not not popular enough and we'll
buy and software up but no he's not
going to do that she's going to be the
nominee I do think
uh you you mentioned polling uh you know
there's a pullout in New Hampshire last
week that showed that you know a
majority of Democrats that don't want
Biden to run again now some of that is
because he has come out and said I don't
think New Hampshire should have the
first amendation yeah they did love that
like yeah they're not I mean these are
people who
history around having the First Nation
primary you've been in New Hampshire
many times as have I it is a massive
Boon to the state's economy that they
have this many uh presidential
candidates reporters entourages you know
it's just it's advertising economics
advertising Zone yeah right it's it's a
huge economic Boon for the state so part
of it is that but I do think if you go
and look at polling outside of New
Hampshire there's lots and lots of
people including lots and lots of young
Democrats who don't want Joe Biden to
run again now those polls rarely ask why
right they just say do you do you think
Joe Biden should be the nominee or do
you want Joe Biden to be the nominee but
you know my strong sense is that there
is some trepidation about nominating
someone of his age uh to another
four-year term I mean we people went
crazy when Ronald Reagan was Ronald
Reagan was
right and so
I think you're right I mean I think
they're I think there is a again if
there wasn't if I didn't have control of
sort of the reins of the nominating
process which he does in which you know
incumbent presidents generally do it's
not like he's unique in this but if he
didn't have the full reins of the
nominating process is there
Lane where you could run as a sort of
generational change that you know look
Biden did a lot of great things but you
know the future of the democratic party
can't be an 82 year old man who will be
you know in his mid to late 80s by
excuse me by the time he runs for by the
time he's finished in office like that's
that's a case that there is some polling
data at least that suggests there's
interest there again particularly among
younger voters uh younger Democratic
voters so it's one of those things that
I think there's a constituency for it
I'm just not sure there's a candidacy or
a candidate for it yeah in in part
because of what you said before which is
look if you are an up-and-comer you're
not going to ruin your relationship with
the current president and most everyone
of importance in the DNC by thrusting
yourself into this race which is one
reason why I think that Joe's going to
declare for re-election and then
everyone is going to say JoJo he's our
guy uh and get behind and when I say
everyone I mean everyone in the
Democratic establishment is going to say
uh JoJo he's our guy uh and I think that
the Democrats end up having some version
of buyer's remorse when the clock takes
forward to 2024 and Joe is uh running
and you know maybe there there are some
economic problems maybe he's facing a
younger more Dynamic candidate than
Trump like but this is what I I think is
going to happen I I personally see this
as a deeply unhealthy process
you know in the common sense it's like I
just don't think this is great
if you know me you know that I believe
we should own our own data and right now
big tech companies are tracking your
every move online one way you can
improve this situation is to use
expressvpn I like expressvpn and use it
on several devices you can use it for
under seven bucks a month after all I
don't want my personal data to get
access for the profit of someone else
plus I like being able to access content
from around the world just literally tap
one button on your device to turn it on
and you're done no more big companies
snooping around my business if you don't
like big Tech tracking you and selling
your personal data for profit it's time
to fight back visit
expressvpn.com yang right now to get
three months of expressvpn for free
that's
expressvpn.com Yang once more
expressvpn.com yang
foreign
[Music]
on the other side you mentioned uh Trump
obviously running and then Nikki Haley
is going to run we think DeSantis is
going to run
um I think Larry Hogan runs I think Mike
Pompeo runs uh I think I personally
think Tulsi gabbard may run
um in the Republican Lane
um are you hearing about any other
candidate oh Chris Christie uh hello
Miss Chris Christie no and Mike Pence oh
that gets us to eight I was gonna say
Mike Pence for sure I think I think
that's the the bulk of the serious
people uh Tom Cotton the senator from
Arkansas took himself out you know Josh
Hawley from Missouri gets mentioned the
senator from Missouri I don't think he
does it for the exact same reason that
we were just talking about why ambitious
Democrats don't run against Biden I
think Holly looks at it and says you
know I have a five
he says 10 chance of winning but like a
five percent chance of winning is it
worth
going in and sort of running in that
regard with those chances or is it worth
waiting and just seeing kind of what
pans out and you know he's 40. so it's
like he can wait around uh same thing
with Marco Rubio I think he would like
to run for president again I don't know
if he he will this time I could see Ted
Cruz running again
um you know he was uh the runner-up in
2016 to Trump I I'm amazed that the race
came down to him and Trump I mean I
think it just speaks to sort of the the
wackiness of the Republican party that
you had Donald Trump and and Ted Cruz as
the final two I would not have predicted
that not not just actually the wackiness
that that undersells it the
lack of power of the establishment to
choose candidates in an Open Primary
race because Donald Trump ran expressly
as the anti-establishment candidate Ted
Cruz was someone who the establishment
hated uh you know for shutting down the
government over Obamacare for sort of
what they viewed as his grandstanding
political grandstanding the fact that he
eventually became the establishment
candidate was I mean no one likes that
guy everyone like everyone's down you
know I mean the fact that such a deeply
personally unpopular figure
[Laughter]
it was the second he he's second yeah he
was a runner up I remember um I could
see
I could see him
till proven otherwise I think the
polling should be trusted broadly which
is the race looks like a race between
Trump and DeSantis with everybody else
kind of trying to benefit from what is
expected to be those two going after one
another and I do think look Trump I just
wrote about this Trump doesn't really
have like a
policy agenda to talk about
um he doesn't he doesn't have a real
Vision I mean to the extent he has a
vision it's a very dark vision but but
he doesn't really have a vision for sort
of like America's next steps the way
that he runs these campaigns is he just
kind of savages whoever's in front of
him right like first it was uh first it
was Jeb Bush then it was uh Marco Rubio
then it was Ted Cruz then it was Hillary
Clinton like that's what he does so you
know I think he's sort of waiting around
for DeSantis to get into the race and I
think it's why you see sort of a lack of
energy around like Trump's campaign so
far he's been in the race inexplicably
he got in November 16 2022. I have no
idea why he did that other than
potentially to make it harder to indict
him uh because it's you know he's an
active presidential candidate it made no
sense from a political perspective he's
the front runner I thought it was to to
um curtail or you know uh short circuit
legal proceedings and maybe just scare
off candidates
um which I which his launch has been uh
very poor and he seemed for the most
part uh disinterested and one note
himself kind of low energy you know uh
strangely enough
um and yet
um it still seems to have worked on the
level that you haven't seen other
Republican candidates declare there was
a recent story saying that no one wants
to be first because they're going to get
uh gored by Trump and then they're
talking maybe have a bunch of us declare
at the same time so it's harder for him
to do it to all of us which by the way I
I found to be farsically ridiculous
because
um if you're a non-desantis candidate I
think you need the time
um totally to get out there and make a
case before the oxygen leaves the room I
totally agree I think if I was Nikki
Haley or Mike Pompeo I or even Mike
Pence I would get in sooner rather than
later for that exact reason once the
santis gets in which I think will
probably be over the summer once
DeSantis gets in the race becomes
DeSantis versus Trump right it's these
all these two warring Titans and two
visions of the Republican party or what
you know generational Clash whatever it
becomes a race that's told through the
two of them I think you have to get out
and make it even if you're at even if
Trump is at 50 and desensis is at 30 and
you get yourself to 15. 10. like you you
distinguish yourself in some way you're
you're not at one or two percent you get
to ten or eleven or twelve percent then
at least the race is written about As
Trump and DeSantis and let's just say
Mickey Haley sort of as the alternative
to that and then if they start fighting
with each other as you know certainly
Trump will do and I would assume
DeSantis will respond in kind but as
they start attacking one another then
you're a credible alternative for people
who are sick of that I'll also add
not Trump or DeSantis and you're at you
know I think the the Nikki Haley is at
like five or six percent Pence is at
eight percent no one is above that other
than the two of them like you need that
time to your point Andrew you need that
time to like build support yeah you need
that time to introduce him to raise
raise money to uh take right to to
introduce yourself to these early States
like to build a national uh
infrastructure that can support like
that if you get some momentum that can
support that momentum these things I
think people always say like I can't
believe the presidential race is
starting already which I understand and
I think it's an abstraction at the same
time the logistics of running a national
campaign are significant from a
financial perspective from just the
building the the totally campaigns in
the states and it takes a bunch of time
it also takes a long time to get known
you know you're you're running for
months and months and much and you think
like of course people know that I'm
running but then you find out they don't
know you need to have it it takes a lot
of
Tyson name and say oh let me go to an
I mean I'm sure you had this experience
oh yeah I declared in February of 2018
uh in the New York Times and uh in no
one cared about the 2024 race that early
on
um but it was the right move because I
was Finding early adopters and doing
podcasts and grinding out events and
also honing my message and figuring it
out uh like my team was getting their
act together because my team was not
exactly comprised of Veteran political
operatives
uh uh and if there was
um an upstart Republican candidate right
now I think that they would get major
press coverage and hits just because uh
you have Trump and then you have the
alternative to Trump who let's say in
your like uh hypothetical as Nikki Haley
I think well Nikki Haley's a big enough
deal where she gets
um all of the uh Sunday morning
interviews anyway but I I think if
you're one of the more marginal
candidates like you probably also would
get uh major press coverage because like
well you know second presidential
candidate of the Republican party's here
absolutely
and and there's a I mean I do think
there is and this doesn't mean he won't
be the nominee but I do think there is
some Trump fatigue both in the
Republican party and in the country more
broadly like I think in the Republican
party there are
a number of people who are ready to have
someone other than Donald Trump in front
of them at all times and you know Trump
schtick and it is a shtick I mean you
know he's only kind of gone deeper into
it over the over the last two years
right like the election is stolen and
everyone is corrupt and everyone's out
to get him and the country's going to
hell in a hand basket like you know
someone with a message that was more
optimistic more forward-looking just
different from his message I think
has you know would to your point would
get attention just because it's not
Trump
um and I think there is a there is a
group of people out there I mean I think
this is what explains DeSantis being
so sought after at this point is there's
a lot of Republicans who just are tired
of trump and are
not for whatever the next thing is I
think the Santa says filled that void to
some extent but I think there's still an
open debate about what the who the Trump
alternative will wind up being and again
everything about the santis right now is
just purely potential uh he hasn't gone
at most people I don't think even those
who say they are for him most people
have not seen Iran DeSantis speech in
full gone out and seen him campaign uh
seen him be attacked and see how he
responds you know I mean a lot of it is
just based on like well he he won
overwhelmingly in Florida
and he's against woke politics you know
it's like very vague
um ideas about him that are popular
within the Republican party but like you
know this better than anyone the the
presidential races more so than Senate
races even more so than house races more
so than Governor's races like you have
to go out and actually show that you can
appeal to people right because these
early states are not California they're
not Texas they're not Ohio right they're
they're not states where you can just
run a bunch of TV ads and introduce
yourself to people you have to like go
and meet people whenever New Hampshire
goes it will be in the early stages of
of the race you know you got there's an
expectation there that you have to go
and meet people and campaign and show
sort of how you do Iowa is the same way
South Carolina is the same way Nevada is
harder because geographically the
population lives basically in in uh
Vegas but there's some in Reno like they
are they are Grassroots campaigning
States no matter what order they're in
and then the Republican side you're
gonna have they're not trying to change
the order so you're going to have Ohio
New Hampshire South Carolina you know
these are states where you have to show
and prove it and I
you know DeSantis hasn't done that yeah
and by many accounts DeSantis isn't uh
the most nationally winning personable
retail politician you know he he he
actually I think performs better in
large-scale media than if he's just
hanging out with you in your hall he
doesn't seem to enjoy Cloud handing over
uh donor wrangling or any of that stuff
he's sort of imperious he comes in he
delivers his message and he walks out
and you know that that's a huge part of
again you can run for Senate in some
ways easier in terms of like lacking a
winning personality than you can run for
president the presidential race like it
or not is very personality driven uh you
know just because you look good on paper
if you go out there and you stink or you
just kind of don't connect with people
that plays a role and I think the
santhis has also benefited by the way
from a slew of positive press
um oh yeah he's more or less a media
creation
I mean he right like he but at this
point like who isn't immediate creation
that's true but I do think he look you
have not seen and you will see right you
will see this but you have not seen the
Deep dive into sort of Ron desantis's
personal life Financial life uh stuff he
did as governor of Florida that is
controversial stuff he did in the house
when he was a member of the house that
was controversial relationship with
Donald Trump like everything at this
point is Rhonda if you had to ask
someone who slikes right they say well
he vote he fought critical race Theory
uh in Florida schools and he's against
wolf politics which is a really good
place to be in the Republican party it's
just there's there has to be more there
there will be a deeper dive into who Rod
the santhis is that's why when people
say like oh he's he's gonna beat Trump
like it or not but Trump has already had
that deep dive nothing seemed to sort of
stop him remember I mean he's he has run
for president twice before uh he has
that there is it is hard for me to
imagine a story coming out about Donald
Trump between now and the 2024 election
where people are like oh that's it like
no more I I can't possibly support him
now you know what I mean so much has
come out about him already
um and I think the Santa says yet to go
through that sort of process I think
Nikki hillius none of the other ones
have right but none of the other ones
have are are currently sitting in as
much of a cat bird seat as Ron DeSantis
is you know he's exactly where you would
want to be he's in the 30s uh he's
behind Trump but sort of has a very
favorable opinion uh among Republican
voters uh he's going to be able to raise
a bunch of money he has a base in a
state that is a significant electoral
Powerhouse so there's a lot going for
him I just think
we know the way this process works once
you get to the point where it looks like
you might be the nominee the scrutiny
becomes much much much more significant
and not every candidate can can sort of
bear that uh and and I think it remains
to be seen whether he is a candidate who
can and I think to your point like there
are intimations that come out of Florida
that he is not warm and fuzzy that is
not someone that he is not someone who
people on a one-to-one basis right like
he's he's at a coffee shop in Iowa he's
not someone he's awful he's not a
smoother he's not like their
conventional like fraternity president
or any of that jazz
right and so I you know again you can
argue well the process shouldn't be
about that it should be about policy but
like the process at least that's
currently constructed is heavily
personality driven because those early
states are so sort of Grassroots
door-to-door focused
um and I and I think it it is an open
question how he wears there
yeah so uh so you have Trump uh you have
DeSantis you'll have let's call it for a
sake of argument eight other candidates
by the time the voting gets going in the
early States uh I agree with you that
there's a lot of trump fatigue
um everywhere at the same time I also
agree with you that that might not stop
him from becoming the nominee and the
and the math I look at is that he only
got 30 to 35 percent of the primary
voters in 2016 and then the other seven
candidates uh split the rest of the vote
that was enough for him to win a lot of
the Republican
states have winner take all primaries so
if you win by a submission yes you get
all the delegates
and I can see that math playing out
again I can see Trump against let's call
it the SanDisk and six other candidates
and maybe DeSantis finishes a close
second to him in in various places but
uh the non-trump voter will get divvied
up
um I think that there'd be a better
chance of trump losing if somehow the
field were to consolidate or to clear
and everyone was just like trumpers the
non-trump
um candidate but I I can't imagine all
of the Republicans uh running buying
into that because they all have their
own agendas and if you remember in 2016
that was kind of the dynamic where
everyone was like oh I'll be the last
one standing against Trump totally let
me see if the other guys I still
remember it's so funny you mentioned
2016 because I was going to bring it up
when we're talking about this I still
remember
there was a story uh there were a bunch
of stories but one I remember in
particular it was like Rick Santorum and
Ted Cruz's people are talking uh and uh
the debate is like can they consolidate
behind one candidate and like the quotes
are like the Santorum people arguing
like well we're definitely the stronger
candidate and the crews people arguing
candidate and like the new people
arguing well we're definitely starting
you know and so that's the problem it's
like
yes in if you could if you could
objectively look at the 2024 Republican
field and your goal was to keep Donald
Trump from the nomination I don't think
there is any debate that your best
course of action would be to find the
candidate who has the best chance of
beating him however you define that
whether it's you know ability to raise
money or or capacity on the campaign
Trail or polling and everyone
you're out of the race except for those
two people because then you have a
direct choice and to your point
you know Donald Trump is not somebody
who who wins overwhelmingly right he he
wins with 35 36 37.
you know and in a one-on-one match up 37
isn't enough but in in a eight-way
match-up or a six-way match-up or even a
four-way match-up where you know uh
Nikki Haley winds up getting 15 of the
vote in in New Hampshire or you know and
keeps DeSantis from from beating Trump
or Mike Pence gets 10 or 12. you know
again these are not you don't need Nikki
hilley to get 52 of the vote for this to
matter you need her to get anything
above about eight to ten and there to be
a couple other candidates and I think
the reality of the the Dynamics in the
Republican party is that
it will inevitably no matter how the
other candidates run it will inevitably
come down to a trump candidate Donald
Trump versus a non-trump set of
candidates or candidate like he is the
prime mover still in Republican Party
politics it's impossible for me to
imagine that Donald Trump is like just
one of a bunch of candidates no he is
almost certain to be one of the last two
candidates standing because he has 30
in almost every state because he's done
this before because he has Universal
name identification
um because he's still in my mind has uh
something close to a Stranglehold on
sort of the Republican Party base and so
there's no scenario by which Donald
Trump I can't imagine the race comes
down to Nikki Haley versus Ron DeSantis
it feels to me like the race will
ultimately come down to Donald Trump
versus someone else and you know if if
it goes on long enough I mean I remember
when the race narrowed to Trump and Cruz
in 2016. by the time it did that it was
May and Trump already had too big of a
delegate lead to your point about winner
take all it's it's like a nerdy thing
people don't like to talk about but you
know Republicans do have a lot more
winner take all states so if you win by
50 points or you win by 50 votes you
still get all the delegates so if if
through March you still have a four or
five or six way field and the field is
basically the five non-trump candidates
versus the Trump candidate you know
Trump is going to accrue a lot of
delegates by that point so by the time
there is this consolidation if there is
this consolidation
it may be too late that was the case in
2016.
uh I I think there's a reasonably High
chance that you find Democrats boosting
Trump uh down this stretch because if
Joe is a nominee he has a much better
chance against Trump than he would
against uh let's say uh DeSantis
absolutely Nikki Haley uh combo
both Nikki Haley and DeSantis are under
Mickey Haley may be over 50 now but it's
close to census is under 50. I think
Biden's great weakness in my mind is his
age
um I you know I know all the talk about
like oh he's a liberal or you know you
can debate all that stuff policy wise
but I think the biggest thing that the
average person
has an issue with is his age like do I
really want someone who you know my
grandfather is 82 do I really would I
really want my grandfather as the
President of the United States I think
that's a very relatable concern for lots
and lots and lots of people to my mind
the best again if you're in an objective
vacuum and Donald Trump you know you can
keep Donald Trump from the nomination
the best approach for Republicans if
winning is the goal is to nominate
someone who is generationally you know
several Generations younger than Joe
Biden to say look Joe Biden's policies
are old Joe Biden is old we need a
change we need fresh blood you know we
need a fresh Vision Donald Trump can't
really make that argument right I mean
it's just these couple years younger
than than Joe Biden it's not like Donald
Trump is a policy Visionary you know I I
think he is I think he is simultaneously
the most likely Republican nominee and
out of the major candidates we've talked
about probably the weakest Republican
nominee in that I can see a path that
Biden runs and wins again on a very
similar message which is like let's this
is a return to normalcy like you want
this guy who's out there pushing like
crazy conspiracy theories or do you want
me who you may not love who you may
think is too old but like I'm not going
to crash the Republic into a mountain I
was on a panel with Chris Christie a
little while ago and Chris said uh a
generic Republican will defeat Joe Biden
and then I said congratulations Chris
but a generic Republican can't win your
nomination
that's exactly right
and so you you wind up so I I think that
Democrats will be looking at each other
saying like are we really gonna run Joe
back uh you know I I like and uh and
then be like well if it's against Trump
he'll he'll win and then if it seems
like a non-trump candidate is emerging
then they'll start freaking out I I
think the the strongest argument and and
I should have mentioned this at the top
when I said you know six months ago I
think there was more doubt about Biden
running both did he want to and did the
party want him you know I think one of
the the things that has really helped
Joe Biden is the re-emergence of Donald
Trump presidential candidate you know I
mean I I really do like the idea of
trump is no longer just theoretical
right he is running he is running for
the nomination it is virtually
impossible to see how he would get out
of the race which by the way is a whole
separate conversation but like I don't
see how Donald Trump goes quietly into
that good night if he doesn't win the
Republican nomination I mean I think
that that's another thing Republicans I
think have to really worry about but
that's a side point I I do think that
the emergence of trump Biden can make
the argument and and K N will look at
beating this guy once
I can beat him again it's it's a very
similar case to the 2020 Campaign which
is competency normalcy
you know uh look up we want exactly we
want we want to look up to our leaders
we don't want to sort of beat America I
remember totally
boss totally
and and so I think the more viable Trump
looks the better Biden looks in a way in
that I think it just makes him
uh it it
strengthens the case to nominate someone
with Biden's profile even at his age
because he's been there and done that
before Oh when I was running against uh
Joe and everyone else in the 2020
primary the number one question for
Democrats was who can beat Trump and
yeah I think that Joe Biden won the
nomination because Democratic voters
decided Biden can be Trump and I think
that you're looking at it now saying
Biden can beat Trump and Trump is
running and that if it was Ronda Sanders
all of a sudden it would be like can
Biden defeat DeSantis and like you know
the answer uh I think would be probably
not and then there would be like a giant
freak out there would also be an attempt
to cast Ron DeSantis as uh you know just
as Looney As Trump
um which some people believe if some
don't I don't know Ron well enough to
know what you know what what the truth
is I think it's a harder sell I think
because DeSantis
you know the criticism of DeSantis
honestly is that he's kind of boring you
know that there's not there's not like
beyond the sort of like face of it
there's not a lot of there there
um
the same way that
that Republicans you know Republicans
try to make the argument like Joe Biden
is just as destructive for America as
Hillary Clinton like it it never would
say boring I think the other critique is
uh cold and non-personable
necessarily if you're the if you're the
party's nominee is not necessarily the
worst thing because I think it's harder
to vilify
Ron DeSantis than it is Donald Trump I
think Donald Trump gives it to you on a
platter in terms of things he says
things he does things he's said and done
in the past I think DeSantis
I mean there is no question that if the
Santa says the nominee the argument
against him by democrats will be he is
too extreme for America right he he
wants to make America into Florida the
vast majority of Americans don't want
that that will be the case that is made
um I don't know how we'll see again with
the samples I think so much of it is
we'll see but we'll see how
he wears that label again I think
Democrat Republicans tried to Brand Joe
Biden as an extremist who is going to
take America backward rather than
forward he was just Hillary Clinton but
a man blah blah blah and like while that
extremist kind of you can't trust them
attack worked on Hillary Clinton
it you know it didn't it was kind of
like well it's just Joe Biden like you
can argue he's like yeah yeah yeah the
character the character the character
Turing doesn't really work as well Joe
because uh most Americans kind of have a
sense of Joe and what his deal is
totally and so I don't know if that
would be true um but look I do think
that
um the best nominee for Democrats is
Donald Trump I I don't I just don't see
any debate about that
[Music]
by the way Joe Biden always a very
winning human being on the trail uh
Charmed me and my wife uh Jill is great
too I mean when you talk about the
personality of uh uh politician or a
President Joe Biden definitely had that
winning uh totally yeah he loves glad
handing yeah yeah but you know genuinely
likes people
um likes interacting with people like
likes expressing uh Comfort or sympathy
so
it sounds like you and I are aligned
that on the Democratic side most likely
nominee is Joe Biden
um it sounds like both of us think that
there's a reasonable chance that Trump
emerges as the Republican nominee again
if it's not him then it's probably
DeSantis though a lot can change and
DeSantis hasn't been vetted and and I
have been through a crucible like it's a
weird one where you don't know how a
candidate is going to respond to The
Crucible of being in a presidential race
until they're in it so you just don't
know I mean you know there were points
when there were there were a lot of
folks that's important
no but I think that's really important
is like you know you when you announced
had some sense maybe what you thought
running for president would be like but
like when it got more serious when you
started to get like people actually
responding to you it's it's a different
thing right it's a different thing for
sure and that's a process that you can't
know until you do it I think that's one
reason why there are a number of these
candidates on the Republican side who
haven't taken the plunge
um because it's actually
everybody don't know this and but I've
seen other candidates too same same
drill so I was campaigning in Iowa New
Hampshire in the earliest days when
there were folks who were uh taking the
temperature some had declared some are
not declared we're talking about Eric's
wall well uh Jeff Merkley Governor
Inslee of Washington State uh Tim Ryan
um
Kirsten gillibrand who declared at a
certain point and and the fact is when
you're going around saying hey I'm
running for president the response is
generally not like oh that's amazing who
are you what's your deal you know
there's a ton of uh of I don't care who
the are you like ignore you
um and that was happening to members of
Congress or Governors or Senators I I
once gave a talk a political talk you
know we would like a stump speech
essentially and it was me and Senator
Michael Bennett of Colorado who also ran
for president our cycle I think Senator
Bennett is a really great smart guy and
we were both giving our stump speeches
in a bar in I want to say it was South
Carolina and no one there could give a
uh you know and so really hard so
for Andrew Yang to be like hey I'm and
so I just made light event had some fun
and just did something and like because
at this point really throughout most of
my campaign like if you didn't give a
about me or like you know treated
me like oh who the are you I was
just like it's cool whatever you know
it's like I'm I'm like like why would
you but if you're a former Governor your
former Secretary of whatever the Hank if
you remember
yeah and then you go around being like
hey I'm did it on people are are you
know like just blowing you off there's
something
really really there's something very
difficult about saying I'm running for
president and then folks responding to
you like you're uh full of which by
the way like even like a gajillion of
these former officials they get that the
only times you don't get that is if your
name recognition is Sky High or you're
famous
um and there's like a subset of these
political figures that have that but
most of them don't like if Governor
Larry Hogan walked into a random bar in
New Hampshire or Iowa or South Carolina
no no who he was by the way Governor by
the way Governor Larry Hogan I think
he's a very very smart personable guy
um uh but I'm you know I'm just saying
like I like I know what what walking in
no it's just the reality it's just it's
just people again like I I think I think
for all of us it's like I announced when
my book is coming out and I'm like just
waiting for it to go to number one on
Amazon no like that's not how it works
that's not how politics works you got to
introduce yourself over and over and
over again and anyone who has not seen
politics up close
it can be really awkward and
uncomfortable to your point like people
are not people most people are not like
us they are not dialed into this stuff
every day they are not like going to a
restaurant in hopes of meeting a
presidential candidate like they're
going to a restaurant to eat and you
just happen to be there you're the
random person yeah totally who's like
you know like coming up to them while
they're like ordering appetizers and I
think that that process is humbling I
think it's uh daunting and I think even
for someone like DeSantis who who I
still think there's going to be times
when he goes to Iowa or New Hampshire
South Carolina where it's not all roses
it's not all everyone knows him
certainly it was the case for Nikki
Haley or Mike Pompeo or or Larry Hogan
or any of these other people we
mentioned like you gotta grind in the
beginning well what's interesting though
is I think Trump uh really ended up
leapfrogging a lot of this process by
virtue of his celebrity I mean he didn't
find out he just sort of did his like
giant rallies and was like Hey guys
never knows who you are and the rest of
it what's interesting is DeSantis has
essentially been given a version of the
same superpower by virtue of the media
and his National notoriety where uh like
I think he could just show up and do
like a one-to-many type rally and then
like and then skip town and there'd be
some grumbling activists being like hey
he didn't come kiss my ring or whatever
but like he might be able to get away
with it
um the other candidates can't get away
with it I think you have to do the thing
and you know and it's unclear to me
whether DeSantis has been given that
Halo
um I think he might have
um anyway but like that that's a I think
that that's a really interesting
question with DeSantis which they're
probably trying to figure out now which
is like what kind of campaign does he
run right does he run that kind of like
uh Giuliani Circa you know
2008 where he's running on his celebrity
he kind of comes into town with like he
comes into Waterloo Iowa with like eight
black SUVs he gives one speech he leaves
Waterloo Iowa with eight black SUVs and
flies privately back to New York City
like does he does he run that kind of
Campaign which is like a front runnery
Camp you know I'm already known I don't
or does he run like a more
Howard Dean in Iowa you know nobody
knows me but I'm gonna spend all my time
there you know does he run more of a
Grassroots campaign does he try to run
some kind of hybrid where he does he is
trying to you know is he gonna be the
guy who tries to visit every County in
Iowa or is he going to be the guy who
does like you know Des Moines Sioux City
and and and and Cedar Rapid like you
know I think that that's an open
question because he's like teetering on
the edge to your point like he's not a
celebrity like Trump he doesn't have
Universal name and ID like Trump but
he's clearly
a a category above the Mickey Haley's
and Mike pompeo's and Larry Hogans of
the world right so like how do you run
if you fit into that category and I
think that's probably what they're
trying to figure out yeah if if he does
have that I don't have to deal with the
the
um the activist schmoozing uh superpower
I think that helps him a lot because I I
get the sense that he would not dig it
yep
that's like a that's an open question
you know it's like can can enough
activists undermine him if he doesn't
need them enough you know
Trump obviously didn't really do that I
mean Trump was just like I'm famous
here's my plane here's a big rally so I
don't know how warm a relationship Trump
has with the activist Community but but
again I do think like the Saints is in a
uniquely good position but a unique
position in that he's not clearly not
the front runner but nor is he kind of
in the the like really have to go and
grind out you know every County in Iowa
go to New Hampshire 65 times crowds like
what does that look like as a campaign
so you and I agree it could be Biden
Trump the rematch or it could be buying
some versus someone else but if it is
biting Trump uh I saw one poll that said
58 of Americans would want an
alternative to those two candidates to
to our discussion their combined age in
2024 would be 159. uh Joe would be 82
and and Trump would be 77. uh and I
think that would be a very very clear
emblem to the dysfunction of our
selection process where it's like wait a
minute you have a country or 300 million
people and like we're choosing between
this guy and that guy and so so 58 of
Americans would look around being like
do I have an alternative uh no labels
has publicly uh said that they are
gaining ballot access for a potential
Unity ticket by the way that they're
nightmare or dream depending upon how
you look at it matchup is Biden versus
Trump and they say look if that happens
then we're going to field an alternative
uh or have you heard anything about the
the No Labels effort beyond what has
been publicly reported no I have not but
I think what they're doing is smart I
think the biggest challenge always for a
third-party candidate is ballot access
and I think again it's sort of an unsexy
thing but every state has its own rules
on how you get on the ballot uh some
states it's quite easy some states are
hugely laborious and expensive
um you can't just
come in I mean we sort of saw this with
Michael Bloomberg he obviously ran as a
Democrat but but even if he had run as
an independent just because you come in
and spend 500 million dollars let's say
is a guarantee of very little
um you have to be on ballots you have to
have some party infrastructure I think
that's one of the things people Overlook
it's like the Democrat Democratic and
Republican party infrastructures are
hugely ingrained in the process and how
it works and so I think in order to I
think ballot access is the first
priority
um I think you then have to get on the
debate stage and and to do that you have
to be relatively well funded I mean look
there's
we're not that far removed from Ross
Perot in 1992 and I always remind people
rosborough dropped out of the 1992 race
then got back into the 1992 race and
still got like 22 or something there is
a path there I think it's just you have
to do the unsexy things now which is
ballot access which is trying to find a
candidate that can qualify for the
debates whether that candidate is a
quasi-celebrity whether you know however
you can qualify the debates but you have
to get on that debate stage and then you
kind of see what happens I do think the
best matchup for someone who believes
that there needs to be an alternative is
Trump Biden without question yeah you
end up with a a lane a mile wide of the
country and be like Oh sign me up for
this that's exactly what it's exactly
what you said 159 did you say combined
age I mean you know it's and it's a
rematch of what we just had yeah and it
didn't get better it got worse it's like
a sequel to it and it's only going again
I always tell people if you thought 2020
was bad wait till 2024 like there's no
indication that the 2024 race is going
to be some sort of high-minded either in
the primary or the general election sort
of a high-minded uh intellectual
exercise it's going to be Trump has if
anything gotten more uh extremists more
conspiracy driven more crazy uh in in
what he ostensibly believes and so it
that's not going to change for the
better so I would say that yes that is
without question your your best matchup
again though I think it is it is the
logistical things it is ballot access it
is uh finding a candidate that you think
can make it to your point Chris it's the
candidate if if you had the right
candidate then I think uh it opens up a
lot of eyes and Minds uh very quickly
I'm going to share with you what I think
is the massive opportunity that we're
going to see over the next number of
years the major weakness in the system
is the nomination process and we're
talking through it a little bit right
now in terms of the 2024 cycle so if you
had uh an independent primary or a third
party primary that people could
participate in you could design it
however you want because it's up to you
as a party so you could include New York
California and Pennsylvania very early
on and right now they're essentially
Spectators you could have people vote on
their smartphone and the vote gets
verified via a personalized QR code that
gets sent to their mailing address of
record and then when they scan the QR
code it goes ding your vote has been
verified so you could get millions and
millions of Americans to participate in
a modern process that was choosing
between let's say just for fun Mark
Cuban Adam kinzinger Justin Amash Nina
Turner The Rock like whoever the heck
you know like like you'd have this set
of candidates uh and then millions of
Americans would be like ooh I'm I'd like
this this is more modern they're
actually asking me and then the Legacy
parties would be like no no no that
doesn't matter that's all fake what does
matter is what the six percent of Iowans
decide
and then the average American would be
like wait a minute
because because the Legacy nomination
processes we all kind of are like oh
that's the way it's done but then if you
were presented with something that was
much more modern and different and
lowercase D Democratic then you could
especially now because a lot of the uh
the control of this process you have the
parties with very Antiquated uh uh
nomination processes that by the way I
participated in so you know I can say it
with some Authority and then and then
the second thing is you have the media
saying no like like this is what matters
this is what matters and then both of
those things are getting less and less
uh credibility over time uh you know
like the the number of Americans who now
say they're independent is like 42 to 50
it's about twice what uh who say that
they're aligned with either party uh
trusted media is now cratering to you
know it's like less than 50 percent
um
yeah way less it's actually closer to
you know maybe like like 39
and so at some point by the way the
technology to do what I'm I'm describing
is actually already there uh and you
don't even need to use anything
newfangled like the blockchain you can
actually just use secure internet voting
and then journalists could look at the
back end and be like yeah like they
counted chrysalisa's vote like the way
they did it or whatever
um the the big variables are ballot
access which is uh difficult and
expensive and time consuming um no
labels are saying there's they've
already they're already raising and
spending I think about 35 million on it
which is about what it would cost
um and then whether you have some
heavyweight candidates that decide to
run but if you have the heavyweights by
the way if you had a heavy weight like a
Mark Cuban decided to run then anyone
else who was considering running for
president would all of a sudden find it
much more appealing because they're like
wait a minute I can run in a process
that isn't going to put me through the
the ringer of either the Democratic
process of the Republican process
because you know that those processes
aren't going to give you a fair shake or
aren't going to expose you to the
average voter it's just going to expose
you to the the base of either party I
think that's right
um I think the question is can you get
all of that up and running in time to
have an active
field
in advance of 2024. I mean I think
that's it's oh I'm talking about over
like any of them you're talking about
the next number of Cycles
um or or not maybe I'd say between this
this cycle in decades because I I think
that's something like what we're
describing
um it is I mean it could happen in in 24
but it could also happen in 2832 Etc I
look I think that the upheavals that
journalism and politics have seen are
still not
adequately understood I mean I I see
that every day with you know uh this
doubling down on like broadcast linear
television or doubling down on print you
know I mean like
I think that the reality of all these
organizations is the people who run them
are still part of Legacy Media
organizations or Legacy political
organizations and that change rarely is
going to come from above I think Change
is Going to Come From Below I think that
people are right for change I think that
they're sending us messages that they're
right for change
I think the question is can you get
someone in in the politics sphere can
you get someone who
encapsulates a desire that that desire
for change you know Ross Perot was many
things not all of them great but but he
was radically different than what was
on offer I finally remember Ross Perot
in the giant sucking sound which turned
out to be right by the way and it's like
30 minute infomercials you know he he
looked sounded and was different than
what was being offered by the two
parties
um I think that in a presidential race
the candidate matters overwhelmingly uh
yeah as I said before it tends to be a
vote on personality and likability uh as
opposed to sort of a vote on policy it a
lot of people think of presidential race
is like you go to the two candidates
websites or three candidates websites
and you look at the policies and you
check off the ones you agree with and
you add up the checks and you vote for
whichever candidate has more checks some
people vote like that but the vast
majority of people don't the vast
majority of people are like uh I mean I
always point to George W Bush George W
bush won not really because of Any
policy but because people like that
seems like a pretty good guy and Biden
is the same way it was like that's Uncle
Joe you know like he's he's he sure he
has his limitations he has his
weaknesses but like he's a fundamentally
decent human being so I think that any
third party has to find a candidate who
can encapsulate desire for Change and
credibility you can't look like it it
can't look like uh a a triple bank shot
it has to look like I could I could
imagine this person running the country
I do think that bar is different now
that Donald Trump has been president
right like his background was like a
reality TV star and sort of successful
businessman so I think there's a lot
more people who see themselves as a
potential president I think that's a
good thing
um I think we would benefit from a more
open process
um I again I I think
in theory and open process is man is
manageable and doable I think in
practice it's a little bit harder
because the two parties are so
entrenched and would fight so hard
against it well Chris this has been a
fascinating and fun conversation and a
bit of a trip down memory lane for me
um so uh you have a book coming out
Power Players about presidents and
sports and I I know that this is those
are two things that you probably have
deep interest in you want to talk a
little bit about your book yeah near and
dear to my heart
um yes the book is uh essentially an
attempt to look at the sports
president's played spectated and loved
whether when they were kids or when they
were adults and what it tells us about
them so Nixon for example Nixon was a
very good bowler he actually Bowl the
227 he had bowling lanes installed in
the white house
um there's all these great quotes from
him that have been lost to history that
I I found for the book about the
Solitude of bowling and why that
attracted him and this idea of that
bowling was the sport of the silent
majority at the time
you know in the same it was a big deal
it's true bowling was hugely popular yes
I mean it's not like it is now where
it's like you even you know one person
was like a bowling league that they do
every Tuesday night like it was very
popular both professional bowlers were a
big deal and so he sort of equated this
idea of the silent majority with his
bowling with with sort of his politics
um you know Obama and and uh basketball
you know it's it's very interesting so
Obama only met his father twice
um on one of the two occasions his
father gave him a basketball which at
the time made very little sense like
basketball was not a big deal in Africa
uh where his father was from Obama had
shown himself no real interest in
basketball but you know he has talked
about and written about uh this idea of
basketball sort of a cultural Touchstone
to help him understand what it was to be
African-American in this in in the
United States or to be of mixed race to
have a white mother and white
grandparents and a black father who he
barely knew
um so it's a lot of stuff like that it's
Kennedy and golf uh it's Eisenhower in
golf it's uh LBJ and the fact that
Lyndon Johnson his sport was politics
like he never showed any interest in any
sport ever except as a means to an end
he befriended Richard Russell in the
Senate through baseball Russell who was
like a hugely powerful figure in the
Senate uh from Georgia was his wife had
passed away he uh uh he or maybe he had
never married I think he maybe had never
married uh he he would go to baseball
games by himself and Johnson a new
Senator realized that he could get in
with Russell by pretending that he was
really interested in baseball even
though Lyndon Johnson had no interest in
baseball at all
um and eventually they form a friendship
that leads to many of the things that
you saw in the center of the Civil
Rights Act uh Russell seeing Johnson as
his Protege
um so it's stuff like that I mean it was
it was again they're the two things I am
most interested in in life for politics
and sports and to sort of combine the
two it was really fun so yeah April 18th
uh it will be out I will do a bunch of
events around it but yeah Power Players
uh politics Sports politics and the
American presidency well I need myself a
copy you can follow you will get some
thank you you can follow Chris on social
media uh and he has a brand new sub
stack and I I think you get videos for
free Chris Alissa thank you so much for
coming on let's have you back after a
couple of these characters declare
we need some actual candidates Beyond
Trump otherwise it's too speculative
I'll come back anytime
all right fantastic thanks so much Chris
thanks Andrew
[Music]